desperate to be heard rohingya detainees
lash out at guards
tear gas forces them back inside the
holding facility in hiranaga relatives
of a five-month-old baby say she died
after inhaling the gas
the government says the death is
unrelated to the protest
the baby's parents are among 270
rohingya Muslims who've been detained
for the past two years
I saw my uncle and brother-in-law in
very bad shape which made me feel really
upset they have sustained serious
injuries and I'm afraid that I will not
see them alive again
this man says rohingya refugees
including his brother were lured into
detention under false pretenses
the government took many of us into
detention under the pretext of covet
tests families are being torn apart he
says many don't know what they've done
wrong and are refusing to wait until
they're freed a government spokesman
says the force used against the
protesters was necessary they've been
violent even when they were free a Roman
not free here they were considered a
security threat to the area so that
that's a behavior they behaved like that
they have a bomb mentality they are
aggressive they are not cooperative
the government considers them illegal
immigrants and wants to deploy
to know some hold official Refugee cards
it says the process is complicated
the UN says nearly 40 000 Muslim
rohingya fled to India after myanmar's
military Crackdown six years ago around
5000 have been living in slums and camps
like this one in Indian administered
Kashmir ever since
we are very scared in Myanmar we had a
similar scare and were wondering when
the authorities would pick and kill us
due to the fearful situation in Myanmar
we sought refuge in India unfortunately
we're now facing similar challenges here
rights activists say their plight needs
to be investigated if I go by the
statements of the family members that
they have not committed any offense
they are living here with the permission
of the prior permission of the concerned
authorities
if that is there that means the they
their their detention is unlawful
after surviving atrocities at home the
stranded rohingya hoped their ordeal
here ends soon Christina Harrison Al
Jazeera
foreign